yeah I mean I think I think um you can
like have you ever reached out to any of
these young artists and just like
hey I see what you're doing like you
know maybe try to give them some advice
because you've like you said you've kind
of been
you've you've had to live through what
it's like to be like
thrown in the middle of this
machine that is the music industry it'll
eat Chip it'll spit you out and it'll
you know to stop answering your calls
you know what I'm saying like if you see
somebody making mistakes whether there's
somebody close to you or like you reach
out do you try to give them any advice
or is it really not your place you feel
like you know I think I just try to
lead by example and
let my actions
speak for me at this point in time you
know and if I can Inspire or influence
somebody with something I say on a
podcast with bootleg cash or something I
say on a record or just something that
they see me do you know Vic Mensa does
this for the homeless in Chicago or you
know XYZ uh freeze somebody from prison
I'm like man let me let me let my
actions you know speak for themselves
because in the midst of in the midst of
so many things that we've discussed
um is also like uh
just this mountain of positive impacts
of left on the planet which was has
always been the conflicting thing that I
had to realize like
you can't have it both ways like you
can't have it constantly in beef and
drama and getting locked up for this and
still be
giving away a million point five dollars
worth of shoes in the trenches in
Chicago sleeping underneath the viaduct
in the dead of winter to raise money for
the homeless building water facilities
in Africa I mean like I let those things
speak for themselves but it's not a lot
of people in the history of hip-hop that
have
at this stage like had the level of
impact on people in a humanitarian sense
and that I have also that's not the [__]
that for whatever reason will get that's
not viral it's not going viral bro but
that's human nature though it's like
sit and turn on the news right now you
know what I mean like there's nothing
positive on there there's nothing about
the channel you turn in because bad news
travels fast three people shot here two
people overdosed on fentanyl uh you know
Ukraine is being bombed because bad news
travels fast and we're in a culture in a
moment in society that
prioritizes
sensationalism because it's all about
the internet you know and it's all about
Impressions engagement
likes comments and you get a lot more
likes and comments on arguments
controversies and thing and fear than
you do on like love and that's kind of
like our whole news consumption cycle is
like it's just fear-driven like just
like what do we got what are we going to
be scared about today you know what I'm
saying for real it's all fear-mongering
like I think covid showed us that more
than anything because like we were all
just like watching like at home just
watching CNN and they would just have
like the death numbers just there's like
a ticker at the bottom like it was an
NBA score or something I don't think we
really realize like damn like that like
like that was a really I was like
[__] freaked out to go outside you
know what I'm saying like
and you know
a lot of us got it and survived a lot of
us passed away look at that [__] man I
had covered like twice at least
I might have had it twice too you know I
had covered before we even knew what
cover was I know I had a lot of homies
who were like right around December
January December
I was in bed for like days I just it was
like a fever dream I just remember like
rolling around in bed for days you know
didn't even get up I didn't eat yeah no
for sure